the New York Post says it's got to be
woo after the department of energy
reportedly admits that covid-19 likely
originated in the Chinese lab and
critics are now calling out the
government and media's repeated
criticism of the lab League Theory with
constitutional law expert Jonathan
Turley saying quote for years the media
and government Allied to treat anyone
raising a lab Theory as one of three
possibilities conspiracy theorists or
racist or racist conspiracy theorists
the media guaranteed that we did not
have a full debate over the origins of
the virus and attack those who have the
temerity to State the obvious New Jersey
Congressman Jeff Van Andrews a member of
the GOP doctors caucus and he joins us
now Congressman great to have you on the
program the question I still can't
figure out why why did they censor these
voices what was in it for them why
well we've got a group of people that
just don't like to tell the truth I mean
their New Year's resolution should have
been and we're still in the beginning of
the year to start telling the truth and
let people who know the truth say it
this is not an amazing Revelation I mean
this was a virus we've never seen
anything like before they claimed it
came from a wet meat market and it was a
bat and yet we've never seen anything
that was actually natural like this and
certainly there should have been a
thorough discussion certainly we should
have had a president that was strong
enough to speak with China to really
tell the World Health Organization to
stop lying to us to tell big Tech not to
you know to let people actually tell the
truth and not to repress those that
really know what's going on or at least
have a vision of what's going on Dr
fauci I mean the American people are
sick and tired of being lied to you know
day after day week after week year after
year and this is just another example
people were punished for this some
people lost their job if they had a
different opinion than the really wrong
opinion that was being put out there you
know I
once answers but as you said the
American people want and deserve answers
this uprooted millions of people's lives
from the covid origins the efficacy of
masks the way the school situation was
handled but do you think we're ever
going to really get any true answers
even though they're coming out saying
you know what this might have been right
now but do you think we're ever going to
get the answers that we need well we're
going to dig in in the House of
Representatives I mean the house really
wants to know true answers these are
some of the things we talk about even
during the campaign it's enough people
are tired they want a government that
tells them the truth they want a
government that works for them we don't
work for the government but this is
really I hate to say it this way this is
sick stuff when you you know remember Dr
fauci I mean it isn't only this issue it
was the mask issue it was the very issue
of covet itself if you you didn't need
to wear masks in the very beginning then
you needed it then you needed two masks
then if you got the vaccine you did
didn't need masks and the vaccine would
you would never ever have covet again I
mean it's been lie after lie
misinformation after misinformation and
it's about time we practice this egg
open and really found what's actually
going on you know what's most hurtful
about Wuhan not only did the Chinese and
we and we know the real truth poison the
world on the United States I mean let's
just tell the truth hopefully it was an
accident but not only did they do this
but they lied about it and we have an
Administration that doesn't have the
guts to go forward and get the truth out
of them and we paid for it that's the
worst part of all we paid for the damn
lab and we have a ruling class that
likes to censor speech but I want to get
your thoughts on this you and your
fellow House Republicans launching a new
northern border caucus these numbers are
insane 846 surge in migrant Encounters
in one area of Vermont from this time
last year how worried does every
American now need to be about the
northern border 32nd to you congressman
methamphetamine ecstasy more drugs more
people that are dangerous where this is
I'll make it real simple you cannot have
a strong United States of America
without strong borders all around and
again this Administration is just
opening the country up to the point
where we'll have no borders at all
scary stuff there Congressman Jeff Van
Drew thank you so much for your time
this morning we appreciate it I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis